okay Rope time okay yeah that's jammed
in
okay Cynthia it's gonna be a bit of a
battle getting up there but just use
that knotted rope yep try and brace
yourself out okay it's all good but
you'll get over that yeah you're so
Nimble and strong okay
I don't think I can do that
is
thank you
I could get up you can get a leg up high
then you're away
they go good job Cynthia
brace yourself either side of those
walls
there you go
so well
if it's a little bit awkward again same
technique brace against the walls
a little push out
look at you that is great
oxygen deprived oh my God gold muddy
good job thank you respect you know
that's not easy on your own yeah
[Music]